you
hey welcome to pep talks with a bitter
Buddha that's me Eddie Pepitone huh
right out of the blocks you like holy
[ __ ] it doesn't sound too contrived this
week it doesn't sound like hey welcome
to pep talks with me little boy let's
get it on no it's like welcome to pep
talks with a bit of Buddha that's me
Eddie Pepitone you like a it's a regular
guy listen to his new york accent all
right little business up top winnipeg
i'll be at the odd block comedy festival
this weekend i'll hold it that's
[ __ ] because i know i won't be this
weekend i'll be there next weekend um or
you know what when this airs it's going
to be over so we're not gonna be hey
[ __ ] you by the way we're not gonna edit
this out you know what a lot of podcasts
would be like oh we gotta cut that but
you know what you get it raw you get it
raw and that's the that's why podcasts
are popular because you don't like edits
you don't like networks interference and
so I will be at the Orlando indie comedy
festival on october third at all be my
guest is laffy that where I am
performing which I love and we'll get to
him in a second and so Orlando indie
comedy fest on october third and in
Atlanta at the Laughing Skull September
24 through 27 ticket links are at Eddie
Pepitone calm and here we go my guest
this week huh is a stand-up a writer and
musician you know him from the very
popular who charted podcast his new
record some ethology summer ecology is
available on itunes and bandcamp please
welcome Howard Kramer hello hey how come
you were laughing when I was saying uh
we laugh at other people's like where
they're going right like I can't believe
he's gonna win yeah like I laugh at if
the city has never booked me than I
thought that that is I go oh wait I
might have to go there that I don't
laugh now those are great places
Winnipeg
and Orlando I'd go to both of those
places yeah um I'm I'm more excited
about both of them because I don't go to
those places I got a weekend run you do
Winnipeg Friday than you hit Orlando
Saturday know where I'm not that kind of
that kind of road warrior um no I'm
doing Winnipeg the weiser when you're
not doing it yeah it's a festival and
it's a couple of days i think it's
friday sale be fun yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey it's uh have you ever been in
Winnipeg I haven't been to Vancouver I'm
going back there and I've been to
Montreal right no Toronto it's crazy not
yet we are podcast has fans there that
want us to come we got to get up there
absolutely doesn't happened yet the
Drake thing Drake's from there that put
me off it face you just hear that you're
not into it now you're a music guy so
you're gonna be school and me no um
Drake I just got his last album you did
yes because I was hanging out on a set
and this is what I do the old guy yeah
I'm like so would you like I get a young
young kid and I'm like so what do you
listen to and they're like I like Drake
and I and and they would tell me Kanye
to and of course I felt like we I was
like Kanye really i thought Kanye such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they were like not
as music is really good so I i
downloaded Drake's what's his last album
I'm a legend amo legend of the kill me
I'm a legend is that a set you don't
know that those Leonard Cohen oh wait
I'm talking about calling Jesus Myron
Cohen hmm breakaway i was young i don't
know the names of his uh I don't all
right you know what I got it on the
[ __ ] now ok on it would but I all
right what about Drake why did you bring
up Drake you just brought up Drake he's
from Toronto and boy you hear a lot
about them even even you are on the
Drake bandwagon I didn't know he was
from Toronto yeah the TDOT they call it
they call it up there the TDOT yeah why
like Toronto tdot I don't know how okay
or they call it running through the city
run into the six with all up here it is
either Drake the drake album
is uh I think it's just called true if
you're finding this oh if you're reading
this it's too late oh yeah I put out
that mixtape yeah yeah yeah they were
that he wasn't supposed to put that out
so he put it out and that's the title
hey if you're reading this it's too late
it's already out oh [ __ ] that's kind of
cool i give him props as they say for
that um I don't understand that whole
thing yeah he put it out it was Lady
contractually wasn't supposed to put it
out and then he put it out and then he
named it that so once they see it up
there on iTunes it says if you're
reading this is too late it's like a
message to the record company oh thank
you now if you're contractually not
supposed to put something out how do you
get it he just got out he just broke the
contract its a mix tape so mixtape now
hold it that's something I used to make
to try to land the lady land a lady like
here you go this is what I think about
you don't listen to it now listen to it
when I leave right ah i'm leaving on a
jet plane can't get you out of my mind
imagine if like they were a mix tape but
it was just horrible like raindrops keep
falling on my head and and the woman was
like [ __ ] this guy oh i thought it was
gonna have a little you know van
morrison yeah stony mid so that was my
speed van Joni would you do you ever
make a mixtape for lady um no i didn't i
did and did you gonna date no but back
in the days of like joan baez you woulda
they didn't have cassette you would ever
done it on reel-to-reel hahaha that
likes Wonka like I'm just thinking a
gene eggman in that movie the
conversation yeah did you ever see that
it was like just in the van with the
reels yeah with the real foot the tape
together did anyone go to that did any
guy go to that much trouble to make a
mixtape for a lady before the cassette I
think that's funny making it on these
huge machine and then it's like and it's
like the basement it like you have to go
to MIT to make gear and I like why you
here sir like you have to get a special
pass and sugar well I'm in love
with our girl and I think if I could put
together you know snippets of Van
Morrison Joni Mitchell Bob Dylan um a 20
minute Tony Bennett Simon and Garfunkel
just rely on a Garfunkel this is all the
[ __ ] i was listening to when I was well
then I would listen to the hard rock
[ __ ] i was like i'm a hard rock guy like
the who yeah i love the who when who
comes on my saddle this isn't hurt you
that i have satellite radio but when who
comes on satellite Oh God the who comes
on you like you like em oh I get into it
yeah like teenage wasteland johnette
whistles manager is my name next to her
neighbor no yeah the bass player from
the who that's pretty cool I've seen
packages addressed to Roger Daltrey on
his mailbox so I said what's that all
about his that Roger the singer from the
oh yeah i know it in any sector older
guy older guys like he gets he gets his
vitamins said to me and then when Roger
visits the US this guy hands him off the
vitamins I didn't find that I find that
so bizarre like in other words when
Daltrey comes to the US he doesn't want
have to buy his vitamins willy nilly
yeah he wants that he wants him there
like waiting for him or maybe they're
like special and they can't be sent to
the UK ah ah but it's great as a kid who
loved the who it's like I ain't proud of
myself like wow I'm an adult now and I
have like a neighborly relationship the
gannets Rogers vitamins yeah that's an
LA better than most better than most who
fans did is Entwistle dead yeah in fact
um it was my neighbor who found them I
they would say were in the Vegas I think
I don't know that that part's true but I
think it is and he was like when he felt
like when he found them he like I Howard
I found that how I found out John just
where I got when I was over in bed like
he's telling you like ever
thing what are you talking about about
John Entwistle the base play of the Oh
dead really why are you telling me this
I just got to get it off my chest of the
first fruit most of our nation keeps
things in have you told Pete and Roger
yet and how Rodgers mad at me because
his last package of vitamins got soaked
with Mountain Dew I love mountain dew
you can't get it in the UK so you but
you ruined his vitamins now he's not
talking to you yeah but I should break
that silence and tell him about
Entwistle but in this day of social
media he'll hear about it soon enough or
what about Pete you haven't told Pete oh
he's in a shitload of trouble himself
you know oh boy well hey I hope you're
all right ah you want any vitamins by
the way hey yeah a little damaged what's
wrong others we are st. John's wort um
that's we've killed Roger you can
totally get sage elsword anywhere oh
well what can you get I wonder what kind
of vitamins you can't get I think it's
probably HGH or something you know is
that is that really muscular he's like
you th th no but I I saw Daltrey sing
Tommy me and wrath went and at the
Hollywood at nokia waiter it's probably
two summers summers ago that's Dave
wrath by the way for those of you worn
in the business day breath is a very big
manager here in Hollywood yeah so you
guys went to yeah he went we went and
anyway doctor was singing with his shirt
open you know and he's like pushing 70 s
got to be so I'm phase ii still caught
in [ __ ] he's pretty good like that you
know when you fly you see that picture
in the magazine i like the old doctor
you're still muscular that's what he
looked like holy [ __ ] yeah i guess you
know if you're a rocker you gotta stay
stay hard how about all these bands that
these old bands and there's still like i
talk to people about oh and i can't even
think of a band's name but like oh I'm
going to see
owns stones you know car van Halen yeah
and and people saying the concerts are
still great what that they still put on
a good show I never saw a van Halen
before so I saw him when they had
Wolfgang at the staple center a few
years ago and I loved it I was just so
excited to see him but it was funny yeah
i mean i mean i hope that i'm doing arm
like I want to be doing stand-up like
when I'm like I still want to be doing
it when I'm like a 80 yeah if i get 2 80
like but still like I'm not like a joke
I'm not like oh god this ancient mariner
is gonna do stand-up it'll be like I'm
still be on top of how are you gonna
stay cutting-edge at that age I just
just died you know God would just be if
I'm gonna send I'm gonna send people in
the heckle you just to keep you doing
okay don't take it easy on keep them on
god I do have a bit of a hearing loss
already so me too you too yeah this is
from headphones no you know what mine is
funding this is [ __ ] I'm pissed about
it i sanded floors in staten island and
these machines will our they were so
loud no ear plugs check it out the guy
whose business it was he was and I was a
big big big like we used to get so high
me and this other guy who we were a team
we were a team and we would get really
high and [ __ ] lay hardwood floor like
put it in and then sanded and the guy
who ran it he did sometimes he wouldn't
give us the proper [ __ ] ear equipment
right and i think i got it from that wow
you know tinnitus i have tinnitus which
is just a constant ringing yeah of the
years it's like I'm always picking up a
phone like is the phone ringing honey no
it isn't that bad but it's like W it's a
weird chasers you hear weird stuff yeah
you like justice you know what it's it
for me it's like background it's like I
kind of just live with it but sometimes
like it varies like sometimes it'll be
louder than other times I mean sometimes
I could drive me nuts Edna yes like
David Berkowitz started that way
one of our great serial killers uh David
Berkowitz I they were [ __ ] showing on
BBC they were like this week in history
they were showing Berkowitz like is this
summer of do you remember the summer he
was doing that so summer your big
slightness segue and right into Howard's
[ __ ] wheelhouse there you go summer
have a summer you got you can't skip it
you got to have it the undeniable season
have a summer hey pick up the new album
summit ology it's on bandcamp it's on
iTunes it's a lot of fun people like it
yeah i was listening to it i was
listening to yesterday it's good it's
good yeah um thank you that's a fuse of
praise from Eddie it's good good that's
what I tell the kids like I you know
i'll be on a set going have you heard a
howl kramer summit ology and like what
what are you talking about how a Kramer
stomatology who charted he also does
music it's good it's good like what do
you what'd you think of this summer I
mean I do you get to pray I mean your
summer guy yeah yeah mmm know what do I
get depressed when it's coming to an end
oh absolutely yeah I think that's why I
tell people to have one because if you
don't this is the way you feel I mean if
you didn't have a summer it's true this
second part of august early September
it's tough you realize you left it all
on the table you try to cram in the
summer sometimes yeah like now it's
funny talking about this here in LA
because to me it always feels like
summer pretty much well January we can
get a super hot heat wave good but that
doesn't mean you have on a summer true
and you can't have a summer in January
it's not summer so so you're a summer
stickler which is like summer [ __ ]
we're talking and could be a song title
for this hahahahaha some mistake I'm a
stickler your bumper sticker Eddie I
gotta be let me tell you something when
June rolls around nobody's everybody's
like it's all ahead of me then fourth of
July comes maybe that's your first time
in the
who maybe you don't get in the pool
again and then all sudden City you get
out you're looking at the end of august
and yeah I [ __ ] out yeah [ __ ] on you
lash out leave summer lash out give me
your favorite sama sama things to do oh
I've all swimming is it is is 1230 Shalu
oh really you're a big swimmer yeah I
love swimming and dude I don't do it
enough I do have a pool excuse me oh
haha Joe and we're not cutting that by
the way we're not adding that that's a
human being having oh you know get that
well acid reflux yeah that's what they
were behind the scene BTS Margaret can
you rewind it to the acid reflux a
moment that he had it just make it just
comforts me to know that another human
being also suffice ramen Lou yeah group
hey I'm Noah I love swimming yeah I'm an
ocean guy I love uh yeah you live in the
west side near the ocean no i dont i
I've always thought I want to go there
when that's all I've got to do I don't
want to I don't want to be at the beach
and there we go i gotta be back in
Hollywood you know that's what I feel
about living like like like I've always
toyed with living in Santa Monica Venice
yeah and I lived in Venice when I first
got here and I swear to God I had that
same feeling it was like if I stay here
I'll never get any work done right like
I was like oh I just started getting
that beat i called it beach blame ya
like I was like I became an idiot right
and I feel like that it's kind of good
that I don't live i live on Hollywood so
it's like it's kind of like contained I
can only be that idiot look like in my
mind right right right did you write
down some a stickler I'm write it down
yet I like some no IIIi I just think
like people people who treat it like
it's a regular time of year I liked when
you were a kid you get off school you
got the summit that whole thing and then
when I found out you don't get it as an
adult I thought well that's worse that
teachers do teachers get it yeah they
get a summer they really got a they got
them really immerse themselves in school
all year though it's a tough trade off
that's true it is I I have a couple of
good friends who had teachers and right
about now my friend Helen you know she
works her ass off she's a couple years
away from retiring the New York City
public school system yes he has PS this
sucks but uh man right around now it's
like oh she's starting to feel the pull
of the school year yeah and it's
devastating yeah I mean it's gotta be
it's like what iswhat kid goes through
but even worse because of how many more
times you've been through the cycle he
says yes and go back to school now for
the 40th years that's how that's right
kids all you have to do it don't ya
right yeah by down hey no offense the
teachers out there but they do a great
job with the kids and uh they really did
oh jeez what is that I think I dropped
the thing it was like a karmic payback
for me and making the teachers feel bad
no no I didn't think you were making fun
of them you know okay good yeah by a
stickler hahaha um so talk about a
little bit about I now I love the
podcast who charted with a cool app
what's cool apps i can't pronounce her
last name oh cool of eli sock yeah you
and cool up big podcast and you go over
and this did it I love it because you
got you gotta check it out it's on
Earwolf right yeah or is it on how now
oh whoa the old ones were yellow no no
Sega usual how so no yelps been done I
[ __ ] that up yeah that should be part
maybe they're gonna buy it we count down
the top-5 in music movies and more and
right we have fun I always I oh I've
been on it twice and I always get a kick
out of all the [ __ ] that is which you
have to be up on what everybody's uh uh
yeah but I like it I like being like I I
like being up on it and no one what it
is and I'm stand like I wouldn't came up
the idea for the podcast like what could
be a place where I get to talk about
this stuff yeah I like I don't so I
my reign on a couple of things that are
yeah I don't like I don't like most of
what's on the charts but I like knowing
about it exactly yeah exactly because
then I feel like when I know about it I
feel like I've got the upper hand on my
audience right like I know what you Fox
do with your life and that's a comic
isn't that what you're supposed to yeah
yeah yeah but i'm bad at i'm bad at it
because i also have a rebellious side
where i'm like like i think well I think
what Hollywood puts out in general like
a broad statement is not that great I
agree like um I saw a train wreck I
really wanted to like it I heard it was
uh uh you know it's getting all kinds
good rotten tomato reviews i know so
many people in it yeah i think they get
did you did you say I I and I know
you're not supposed to say that cuz we
know every day in the movie and I
support them absolutely and teachers as
well my support teachers and I support
the people a train wreck yes horse you
get in residual checks feel free will go
to lunch no my thing is just Apatow
movies in general I found him to be I
find all movies to be too long and then
Apatow really he leaves a lot in that's
uh yeah you know that seems to me like
it could get cut what did you see it yes
well I thought there was no chemistry
between Amy Schumer and hater yeah it
was like what I'll [ __ ] like that and
then oh and and but then like it was
like a like I'm dying for a funny funny
Hollywood comedy I'm dying for one what
was the last one that we had that was
like kick ass [ __ ] funny maybe uh
that's putting on the borat maybe or
yeah oh that was so fun yeah that was
funny the first one right yeah oh man
well you're glad hey that he really like
he made me [ __ ] laugh out loud I
didn't see his last 12 dictator one I
saw I liked it better than most people
but it wasn't it was more scripted it
wasn't as they did not that's crazy wait
didn't I remember when he I remember
that Todd Phillips was originally the
direct
for the borat really Todd Phillips who
directed old school old school that I'm
you ready I could have had a great
career but Todd didn't put me in a
hangover I auditioned for it and and did
make it so now I'm the nitty-gritty
outsider but you're gonna you're gonna
turn that thing around oh that's that's
a lil up snob no but uh anyway he was
directing boring and they went to that
rodeo to remember the rodeo yeah I hope
you guys remember this if you haven't
seen borat you know rent it I don't know
if you rented downloaded whatever you
whatever you believe is treason I think
it's gonna be like a dart in the neck
pretty soon like like you're gonna go
into a little like it's gonna be club
where glowstick single i'd like to see
I'd like a little can i get i got like
to get five men whatever x is called
these days and then I'd like just a dart
neck like you want to see a movie and
they just shooted dharti and now it's
someone just hit good fellows just shoot
me I think I like the idea anything to
avoid pain cable no ma'am do you have
the table at the Kaiba life dude I need
to do it it's great i do it i need to do
it cuz they drop [ __ ] kids don't watch
it they don't they like a hulu in it and
Roku Roku in your net yeah youtube
everything but oh really yeah I'd
they're smart because the cable thing is
a big land i missing man yeah i watch it
for sport but it's like I went to you
know like if I go to a hotel now I I
turn on the cable and it's just like I
feel like I'm cranking up an old
Victrola haha hey I can't just go do
exactly what I gotta see what day it's
awful yeah yeah yeah yeah but I just
wanted to talk about for second the
borat thing rod Phillips was directing
it and then you know sacha baron cohen
went into the rodeo and the rodeo scene
and he starts talking to the crowd like
yes let us drink the blood of the Iraqis
like he gave
speech to the to the quote-unquote the
Patriots there i think it was in texas
the rodeo at denver and I and they
started wanting to [ __ ] kill him
because he started saying all this [ __ ]
like let us drink the blood of I can't
do it I forget his voice now Cinque let
us drink they blow down all of the
Iraqis whatever he would like he was
going off the wall about yeah the
patriotism and and they they had to get
out of there really quick and those was
like I'm not I'm not gonna [ __ ]
directors oh he died it was jumped he
got out of the movie and I Larry Charles
right to know it's funny because I my
friend knew some of the camera guys who
shot the wrestling footage oh ho gai x1
that was from the you know the Bruno the
next one but there was this uh i think
it was bruno no knowing in that was
Borat in borat he wrestled the [ __ ]
fat davidoff is his name what was his
name the actor who played him he owns
owes you out here this this dip French
Dip place did you know that there's
another guy I'm talking about right the
actor who owns a French Dip place yeah
you did the wrestling scene with the big
fat nude guy right when they were new
dressing is that what you're talking
about yeah I think yeah my memories
horrible hahahaha mine is too anyway
they were the same thing they were just
the guys who had to run and to save
their lives they hard to run run
screaming out of this rescue take such
balls do ya like I I'm not up for like
that kind of yeah you know Lance banks
you know Lance yeah he worked with the
jack you know shadaal the jackass stuff
we did yeah and uh and I I don't know
how they do it just to be on guard all
the time you know what I mean ah any
moment someone's gonna like I guess
that's kind of the driving you know
force of it or whatever yeah it'd be
funny to like do a podcast that's like
really dangerous like hey everybody
we're broadcasting here like you just
find places you shouldn't be like you
set up your recording like in a
barbershop and like you just say think
you're waiting for hair
and you're like hey man we're in the
back of this old-timey barbershop and
I'm talking with how it Kramer Howard
will your favorite movie hey before
y'all get the [ __ ] out of here we gotta
go folks you know jaws edius I'm integer
but I'm gonna ask you about a couple of
movies all right this summer cuz you see
a bunch of no no I don't see them and
you just no no I went on well yeah I
ant-man all to all the Marvel movies
this one might be better than the rest
of them they're all the same movie they
are the same tone and I grew up as a
comic book fan but I never liked it
never seemed to me that they I don't
care I don't need to see it on screen hi
Christine yeah it makes it makes it look
more fake to me than if I were to just
imagine like Daredevils running around
in New York somewhere right when I see
the right the movies it makes you look
more fake so you're kind of a purist
with the comic books like let's keep it
to the comic books yeah but I don't read
them really anymore hi but you used to I
used to read them a lot and then I'm I
don't know I just that was a freedom
that was a problem with me with the
movie pay it forward I had read that
Nick wey Tom exam in a graphic novel i
had read pay it forward Oh in a graphic
novel graphic novel be no kidding I
don't that'd be funny like glue it [ __ ]
I used to doing anyone else podcast now
I get it why people come in and they're
like what's he talking about it's hard
to pay attention to people like i
usually have honestly two volleys like
even if i see people at a party or
whatever i can keep it going for like da
da da and then you throw back down to
that then I go did I not beyond that
it's like I can't I don't like we gotta
do an hour with 28 minutes in uh I hear
you we're doing great now we're doing
good ya know but I well you have a
co-host to like I just did straight cool
app is great she keeps it moving she
does she does those it's good to have a
co-host well you know also we countdown
the songs the top five songs then we'll
count down the top five movies
those breaks yes so things are always
things are always moving forward how I'm
not on wine there are like and you've
already sense that a couple time they
were like big like like all of a sudden
like i'll have like just just what you
were talking to be like no but and you
get a little panicky because you know
the dead air you're like oh well wait a
minute how do I keep this [ __ ]
conversation going right on yeah yeah
you know when you get along nervous yes
could they cut a commercial in or
something soon as that pause hits no I'd
like to give it to them wrong oh no okay
and we're working on advertisers do you
have advertisers we have some seems like
some weeks we read ads and then some
weeks we yeah and people haven't totally
bought in to the podcast thing yet like
they dip their like I think the
advertisers are dipping their toes in
and then they're dipping out like I was
sponsored originally here by Exxon Wow
and Exxon and then Royal shall and then
Royal Dutch Shell Jesus they just
started drilling in the Arctic and I
really wanted this wow you got any
fracking frack er hello yes frackers
hello I'm Eddie Pepitone today's podcast
was brought to you by Royal Dutch Shell
we are now destroying the only pristine
part left on the planet because we need
to make a few more billion dollars Royal
Dutch Shell and proud sponsor a pep talk
and then I go into like so ant-man what
do you think and it's like not their
audience at all what is the audience of
an oil company everybody because
everybody uses but who do they gotta get
the word out to that they're destroying
the land hey Bob you know we're making
sure this is royal dutch shell now hey
Bob you know we're making so much
[ __ ] money why don't we just put out
ads alerting people to the fact that
we're destroying the planet and you know
the hurricanes and typhoons that have
been so destructive or directly related
to what we're doing ecologically and
let's show pictures of these gorgeous
creatures that are becoming extinct
daily and then people they they don't
wonder if it's us they know it's us they
feel better about everything ow I'm
gonna make this point again you need to
get back on yours Olaf all right point
taken let's not do the ads Margaret get
me to Zoloft and a little little water
Margaret is right for secretary okay
it's right in that one guys that were
and that one is the secretary all right
so all right I named one movie I named
ant-man and that's a good point by the
way my wife big comic book personnel she
does like the movies yes she does like
she she and I so I go to them and I kind
of got into iron man the first worst one
yeah and then the second one I kind of
get tired of robert downey jr's like
[ __ ] little like you know little
wisecrack and [ __ ] like all right you
know she's the chick yeah oh yeah that's
like enough man I one of those is enough
I think for sure right one is enough but
they do I think they're up to three yeah
they've done three I would love to see
Bob Dylan as Iron Man laughs switch up
the casting like wow hey uh how would
that go working on the news a new visa
Alma but I have to do it that was your
ID because I need a break occasionally
just what we were talking about yeah you
know what I mean on what other movies
are we uh this is gonna be I saw
straight out of Compton that just came
out so mo UN wa yeah how is that doc is
it a dark aura it's a biopic oh I like
my open you do i do I usually do I love
not unit you know they're so they're
usually very cookie cutter so they
always got and take those that they
always have the same scenes and amaru
times true but there's a domestic
problem at some point like a god damn it
you don't understand me don't you
[ __ ] touch me right and then he turns
a corner and thinks of a song that's
super famous and it's all like condensed
into like three things three important
things I got to happen in the same scene
you
I mean yeah he loses his wife then he
thinks of the hit then it takes the
picture the name some famous ones
because the 1i think it was the Ray
Charles well Jamie Foxx and wrightwood
that was a good one uh there's many of
them buddy holly there's a day duh geez
there's uh I didn't see the Buddy Holly
well Johnny Cash oh yeah i like to
Johnny Cash when I I'm a sucker for them
like i like i like to sometimes like
when the store like if the person who's
by oh I it is i'm a fan like i'll just
like i'll buy it and like that the
sentimentality the hollywood
sentimentality of it i'll be like you
know i like to cry and movies I just
cried us you know what movie I thought
it was good was good I saw homes Oh with
Ian McKellen yeah I was just a sweet uh
it's like the opposite of the Marvel
[ __ ] it's like it was like a sweet like
sweet massage it was like no were you
trying to say like a French message like
a sweet message movie or like up there
like no but I cried thing I cried in in
the homes movie man what was cart what
made you cry because it's homes like
last couple of years and he wasn't Isis
he was he wasn't as insightful because
he was keyhole and tell you who murdered
the guy three miles away he still was
good at that but I he was like losing
his memory a little but what what made
me cry well first of all McKellen is
great actor you know when he's not doing
that harry potter [ __ ] yeah you know
when he's doing real stuff um and that's
no offense to i have a lot i got a big
harry potter following here mom I
thought that was his best stuff but good
what did you see any lecture but harry
potter I hope that I mean I i I've seen
it I dabbled no I mean I know what it is
I don't think I don't put on any way he
made you cry because no because because
I there's a little kid that he kind of
uh takes on as like a surrogate son it's
like a father-son thing from out you
don't like the father's I think too
emotional I cry to feel the dreams me
too I mean yeah that stuff will make me
cry I maybe feel good dreams man yeah
that Kevin Costner yeah yeah costume
makes me cry a lot that's a funny thing
to say like that would be how great a
bumper sticker would that be Kevin
Costner makes me cry a lot a lot there
may just a funny bumper sticker where it
would be intriguing people don't wonder
why he needs to get word out about that
you think people would pull up and go
why why does Kevin Costner make you cry
a lot and I would say just something
about him and then go like just hit the
gas boom what a fun life you will have
with that stick Kevin Costner like I
think it would be a funny idea to make
weird bumper stickers like that like
Kevin Costner makes me cry a lot or honk
if you like the dead dead silence of the
space between the stars burn there was a
[ __ ] chip my writing partner had a
sticker discards in hooray for Gregory
pecks ass no because that was the name
of a local improv group and it used to
infuriate me just because I would think
of all the mental manpower hours that
are going that people just every single
day someone sees that sticker and has to
process it try to figure it out and I
just dismiss it yeah this is wasting
everybody's time by the way that's one
of the funniest names for an improv
group I've ever heard hooray for Gregory
pecks have good one today did they do
well what it's rad its rad I like random
[ __ ] you do um but you brought up
something national geo you're doing a
little writing for now seeing a random
[ __ ] hey there's a new comedy on
National Geographic place for comedy by
the way that's becoming the new place is
it hahaha like
honey can you put national G always has
got a hilarious take on nature are you
tired of getting your comedy from in
comedy central Johnston know this would
be the ad Jon Stewart's left Stephen
Colbert is left Comedy Central is death
haha what's next national geo and it's
just you know a picture of the universe
and like a big leopard arching its back
in the Sun and then you just hear a guy
laughing in the background nobody tell
me what are you working on oh it's a
sketch it's asked us how it writes out
here Howard rights in I mean you're
you're a master of a lot of trades yeah
you're a great stand-up you're you're a
musician and you write on lots of chosen
you sold out shitload of pilots which
I'm jealous of woe be jealous of the
guys whose pilots got made into show
hahaha now that's an amazing thing to me
you sold you saw you and chip were
writing chip Pope yeah you guys sold we
show the probably a dozen pilots but uh
mazing to me if they don't go on the air
then the guy who sold one pilot that
became a shows is going to be way better
off so but now I'm thankful that we sold
all those and we had a lot of great yeah
a lot of great times yeah yeah this is
you like check it out like like at the
party oh we're gonna just get maja I
gotta get a risk our garrison some um
yeah but tell me tell me about that
national geo oh it's uh yeah it's a
crazy idea but they're doing their first
comedy show it's historically based
sketch show some historically based like
let's say take me to one of the tyke
Rome there you go could be romatic
that's historical yeah I mean war z land
on the Rome it was so that was so
[ __ ] broad how about you know like a
certain battle like the Trojan War there
you go could be that you said you can't
talk about it a lot right I don't know
if I
can but I mean right I can talk more
than this but I mean like it's basically
if you watched SNL you might say a
modern-day sketch we that has no
historical resonance we wouldn't be able
to do that we can watch without resonate
historically yes oh but it's a lot of
fun yeah yeah I'm picturing a couple
ideas here this is you at national geo
Napoleon is getting a [ __ ] in a
dunkin donuts now yeah listen to me hear
me out all right and the show run is
very like he's he the showrunner is like
a famous historian like it's it's either
barbara tuchman i'm trying to think of
phases Wow Cornel West what is it he's a
historian yeah Oh Hopsin Eric Hopsin
yeah is one of the big yeah I read a
little bit IRA copson is the showroom
he's like the biggest organs versus your
audience know him I'm probably a couple
of people okay yeah my audience is I
think my own ease is pretty smart yeah
yeah I think I think grabs from the
emails I get there press my grad student
types some some professors couple of
professors you know because I throw out
[ __ ] like Eric Hobson i'm probably
mispronouncing but he wrote like he'll
write something like the age of empire
but the the age of industry like
covering hundreds of years and its
really good [ __ ] it's really well
rebuild arete every them that's the
history of philosophy right well so yeah
or does he do history too yeah it's like
yeah he does history too he and his wife
oh that's right you're right it isn't
life I I used to read uh will durant and
and now they're doing on the flock they
don't have you don't be great a
philosophy channel who no one don't wins
doing phone not visual it's not visual
someone's gotta figure out how to make a
visual yeah yeah you're right to TV TV s
did you see the [ __ ] Seth MacFarlane
produced you're not doing again cosmos
cosmos I thought that the animation in
that was not
oh really i was gonna what did you hate
it okay it's a it was not my view of
what i need to know about Earth it was
like all over the place she's on a wacky
spaceship I don't buy his low that's
right they did this face there was good
moments good CGI stuff I don't know
right right right too much space too
much space I think I'm not into space I
talked about on my show I think that's
funny by the way it's just as such a
preoccupation with mmm and even if they
find stuff we already know that they're
not gonna I agree by the way and I
talked about it I talked about it in my
act to that the reason why people like
for instance they just started getting
pictures of Pluto right right i don't
know if that's chart just the top five
planet let's go to who's John in top
five planet coming in at number five
mercury in retrograde well went
backwards they found Pluto and you say
uh what oh the reason why I mean this is
one thing i do a mac that people get so
into Pluto because they don't want to
face any kind of reality down here I
yeah exactly right they go live they
never have to go there that's for sure
the ocean has alien life in it or life
that we know as intelligent what go talk
go try to talk to that if because if
you're waiting for Pluto to become
accessible I mean I I do think it's part
of that they don't have to actually do
anything so they can just sit there and
be fascinated with it well they all at
that you know jet propulsion laboratory
where they devised the arm the [ __ ]
Mars rover in shape I guess loud I saw
that I'm fast and loud some bunch of
guys with tats and chrome they what they
went space with it so what I did was I
turn your car into a Mars rover holy
[ __ ] thank you I'll
oh you got a rover I got Rover for Mars
that would be a funny thing though where
they they unveil the car and it's now
it's a spaceship that's a spaceship
you're not gonna be able to go in unless
you have [ __ ] ow I mean years of
training training I get registered so
basically shows to donate your card to
the jet propulsion laboratory but anyway
all the physicists and engineers who
celebrate the fact that they landed this
craft on Mars their [ __ ] jumping up
and down there like we did degrading and
I'm just thinking yeah that's kinda it's
kinda it's it's it's it's a great feat
or whatever but I'm like down here on
earth everybody's suffering the planet
is going to ya and nobody's fixing this
fun right they're not fixing this know
exactly it's like what do we do with the
ocean right we eat whatever we can pull
out of it and then we just put garbage
into it right then it's right here so
what are you gonna do millions and
millions of miles away you're going to
do the same thing if you can kill it and
eat it that's what you'll do if not
you'll fill in the garbage yeah you're
not gonna be flying around with a wookie
as your co-pilot go talk to an octopus
we're so far away from space being any
kind of I agree or I even though people
tell me in in in in all the science in
the space exploration they come up with
a lot of inventions that are used on
earth right the microwave satellite TV
oh yeah all that [ __ ] well satellites
yeah which they use basically for
nuclear weapons right I don't say don't
explore it but it there should be so
much more money going into ocean
research because we already know there's
life there we already know we're harming
it so we should really be focused on
that this is where I came to get that
word out hmm yeah why ocean have you
been reading about the your are you
vegan ya later I'm vegetarian I'm not
full vegan cheese could yeah it's the
last thing that's hardest to get rid of
a lot of people say that
that wasn't hard for you I just did it
nice you know I mean I I did it I had a
guy you know had a couple slips and [ __ ]
but yeah you know then eventually I mean
soy cheese is and isn't one of the
greatest taste treats what planet but I
gave away I gave it up I just gave up
cheese I gave up everything else and I
feel pretty good about it I got to move
into that last phase yeah because I know
the dairy industry is brutal right like
they're just [ __ ] rude I mean they
don't yeah they don't give a crap to the
animal I'll give a crap deja it's just a
brutal industry so it's nice when you
can [ __ ] give it up and go okay I'm
not party yeah no absolutely feel that
machine you know and by the way those of
you who eat dairy out there you know no
worries ah do you think you know you're
just you know participating hey let me
ask you this you're just you're part of
a basically a death yes a culture of
data of death now here's the thing if
they made they can make meat in a
laboratory they're starting to do that
aren't they yeah but it's too expensive
right now ah to me to me that would be a
game changer because um yeah all these
people that don't want to give it up we
don't have to give it up but they
wouldn't be killing animals to get it I
guess and but but I don't know I've
heard that that still is like promoting
a taste for meat like that liked about
the vegans are like don't [ __ ] it not
[ __ ] just [ __ ] go without me it
isn't that like the sex abstinence
people say hey don't use birth control
just don't have sex I mean it's gonna be
it would be hard to get people to go
most people don't want to do it they
don't want no I know they don't this
would be a way to get more people I
don't know I don't know much about the
meat lab thing do you know much about
what's charting in the meat lab that's
right number five nobody I know it is
it's too expensive yeah I think it's
like yeah like three hundred dollars for
a hamburger
at calls jr. we have a special plan if
30 of you can chip in ten dollars each
you can get yourself a hamburger like
that be funny like 30 people point like
a little league team right everybody
heck grab your toothpick but um I think
that would be a step in the right
direction i'm a maybe yeah yeah most
people don't want to hear about this
they don't want to hear about it but
what's [ __ ] up now i don't have any
kids you don't have any kids no here's
what's [ __ ] up our carbon footprints
are so low Eddie that's right but in the
ears what's talked about the production
I mean forget about the brutality
animals to [ __ ] raise them you know
it [ __ ] warm as the Atlanta's yeah
all the resources all the water older
they cut down the [ __ ] amazon
rainforest the lungs of the earth to
raise cattle and people don't give a
[ __ ] they're like I want to be able to
eat good food cuz I work yes all guys
what do you mean like what do you mean
Margaret we're going via I come home
from I come off from [ __ ] getting my
ass kicked all day I get my ass kicked
all day in the world I can't have a
steak al al you know that we talked
about this they are cutting down the
lungs of the earth to raise cattle in
Brazil that's what they're doing so
that's why we're going vegan now you
have broccoli in front of you you have
quinoa the broccoli is sauteed and
garlic onion and pepper it's delicious
with a little coconut oil the quinoa has
basil and lentils in it don't don't less
things for me Margaret okay I feel like
I'm in an episode of ant-man ma al you
using that reference totally wrong a
totally wrong first of all ant-man is
not an episodic it was a one-off what
are they listen and they that's the
nether and they didn't list anything an
ant-man you know what they should list
an ant-man all up Paul Rudd stones
because he does too many
he and everything's a lot of stuff I
guess he's very so I I tweeted something
about our Paul Rudd being in too many
movies you know in one of my eye I call
him anger tweets you know I'd like like
what the like like I'll just like
sabotage myself like because I met Paul
Rudd backstage at UCB super nice guy oh
yeah really sweet dude egg but anyway I
was like one night I was like what the
[ __ ] like I heard like you know I saw a
commercial Paul Rudd was it another
movie I was like why the [ __ ] is Paula
and a woman tweeting back because he's
good-looking unthreatening not yesterday
not threatening good-looking likeable
all this [ __ ] and then she goes that's
why he's in every movie and I just
favored it it yeah she's right huh my
anger tweets are always followed by ah
[ __ ] really why do I get involved with
this [ __ ] on Twitter no less oh so
did you get an initial high office and
in it yeah that's the that's the rush
yeah do you are you a big tweeter and
all my thigh ever since Twitter came out
I've been trying to figure out how it
could fit into my life stuff like you
really tweet that much well I'll go
through periods where i do yeah but I've
always gotta sorta like uh like make
myself do it it's not it's not a natural
thing for me to just go oh there's
something I gotta ah yeah yeah yeah yeah
fascinating for me like because I get
into like a big part of my thing is like
being self-righteous about like you know
but know about injustice right like some
you know I'll like like tweet something
out of a you know but did it at and some
of sometimes i like i like tweeting it
but other times I'm like well why do I
be earnest on their kind of thing why
did I want why why was I earnest on
there like yeah it invested right why do
I get invested and and I you know I
don't think I should have attacked uh
all these people like no
I've been getting way better at that
because I have a couple of friends who
go we're like don't don't don't don't
don't tweet that what they're there with
you know don't know they'll like sorry I
thought you know what I'm gonna tweet
yeah I'm gonna tweet this and my friend
will be like no no no no no you don't
need to do that don't go to vote donate
to Powell you don't want to [ __ ] that up
you don't want to [ __ ] that up and I
like very bridge burning things yeah
[ __ ] like that because I was gonna go
after dick cheney the other day and they
were like don't don't don't go no I mean
it wasn't thinking it was a Hollywood
guy you know dick did we cover the
national geo thing and all it's a sketch
show based historically based sketch
show when is it supposedly coming out I
don't know don't watch it how about that
sorry see when you get on podcasts yeah
now if Howard was on a raid on a real
radio spot or a network by to be like hi
I'm Howard quake quake ray hi I'm Howard
Kramer hey National chills got a new
sketch show it's historically based to
show runners era cops from or something
like that erode age of empire please
tune in every Wednesday eight o'clock
national geo watch a place for coming
we're do comedy central that's all news
your you what do you uh if your
millennial you be getting your comedy
from Instagram and Nat Geo I uh I'm uh
it's funny I don't even know if I'm
supposed to be talking about it so I'll
just say yeah it's coming out check it
out cool and we're coming to the end so
what else you got goin wit you want to
promo anything else my dates are going
to be after this uh yeah I want to talk
about summit ology the album check it
out we did a video for gue crews a song
about an orangutang on Funny or Die
check that out Scott people love it and
that's it look for me i'll be coming to
the midwest i'm in chicago at the end of
sep tember Chicago Indianapolis and st.
Louis cool and I'll listen to who
charted and would follow you on twitter
when you get into a twitter jack oh
there you go at howard grammar on
twitter KR e ma are cool well thank you
howard for being my guest that was a lot
of fun
and thanks for having me you gotta come
back home who charted oh definitely i
love doing that and all right uh well
thanks everybody that was a great
episode I just ask you real quick did
you see the Staten Island movie that
came out Oh which I love you Staten
Island get the [ __ ] when did that come
out uh maybe two weeks ago let me to
look it up Oh Webster what's the what's
done I don't know I'll I don't know how
it's doing I just think I know you from
stuff yeah like yeah like the wu-tang
clan the wu-tang and John Calvin the old
actor Oh staten island I don't know
maybe talk about what's most episodes I
love stat now I'm going to look for that
enough stat and I thanks for listening
everybody to pep talks we are a proud
member of the old things comedy network
again follow Howard on twitter at howard
kramer h.o.w ard k r.e.m ER and you can
find his albums at howard kramer dot-com
and rate this podcast on itunes huh you
know give us a good rating it's
important let me know what you think of
the show email me at eep epitome a PEP
itoe @ sbcglobal.net email me we're
going to do a an email episodes episode
yeah hey [ __ ] you you know what it's too
much pressure to constantly be talking
for an hour you know I don't fear should
I face that clock I think it drives you
nuts I wasn't saying about the time oh
you are no but did I know you're staring
at it those Olympic clocks that gives
you the hundreth of the second it just
makes you feel like you're feeling no
time like it's like it's like my brain
is high i just went went to a the mic
was to put it to it even higher degree
of like seconds like so anyway how this
is what it makes me dude like yeah it's
how it so national geo and toxic or a
wine show and you're just trying to get
the clues out fast enough for me to get
all right everybody thanks and we'll be
back next week